well  i gotta hand it to you  you sure do know how to make a fine  piece of hardware  not only that i think she may even be a  better shot than you  well i reckon we'll never find out  unless  fans here go anita  [Music]  every time you're just too bad  ah sorry mate all closed down for the  night  huh what a lovely pleasure i  usually don't do a gauntlet round twice  in one day  but your eyes are just screaming  desperately don't even think about it  right everyone got the clean knickers on  i know he does huh  get her  where's big sister  burn it  well you put up one hell of a fight kid  but it's your lucky day eh yeah  you earned this let's get you patched up  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]